Have you ever sent a letter to
someone living in another country?
Have you ever ordered online a small item
that was sent from overseas? If you have,
you have experienced the benefits of the Universal
Postal Union. The UPU was established by treaty in
1874 to help coordinate the delivery of mail
and parcels under 4.4 pounds between nations.
The UPU has been under strain recently. In 2019,
then president Donald Trump threatened to pull
the US out of the UPU. He was aggrieved that
the UPU scheme of postage rates and fees,
also known as terminal dues, subsidized the
shipment of packages from China, which they did.
Ultimately, the UPU agreed to allow America and
other nations to increase their terminal dues. But
any time any nation feels it is bearing more costs
than benefits, it might quit the treaty. The UPU
should adjust its fees and dues more frequently,
and in consultation with private shipping and
delivery firms, to better match shifting market
realities. Better pricing and fewer subsidies
can keep the UPU viable in the 21st century. Have
you ever sent an international piece of mail or
package? Let us know in our poll. Also let us
know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.